Time for school
And it's no surprise that many of us are determined to study smarter instead of longer
But which study tips and tricks actually work scientifically, and can help you get those perfect grades
First step, research shows that study sessions are most effective in small short chunks
Instead of cramming in a ten hour study session, it's much more effective to spread it out
into twenty thirty-minutes sessions over a few weeks
This is because your brain is better at encoding information into the synapses
in short repeated sessions as opposed to one large one
And this is why even learning different skills, whether it's swimming, tenis, or a singing lesson
often follows the same format
and well, cramming an pulling allnighters may be a ritual, it turns out that this is linked to the lowest grades
after pro-longed study sessions , reasoning and memoring may be negatively effected for after 4 whole days
instead, setting up specific times in a day, or during the week, just to study
primes your brain by creating a routine and
overtime studying actually becomes easier, as your brain is trained to learn in those moments
and well, many of us spend hours passively rereading our notes or highlighting a textbook
studies have shown this to be inaffective
it doesn't improve your understanding of topics. nor does it link key concepts together
it can even be detrimental, as it draws your attention to less important information
Flashcards, on the other hand, are proven to be excellent memory reinforcement tools
Whether, during your schedule study times, or during off times  like a bus ride home
It also helps to have a specific goal for each study session
pick one aspect you're focused on
whether it's balancing chemical equations or learning how to conjugate french birds
if you can't explain it simply, then you don't understand it well enough
if students in individual, were asked to learn  a passage
and then half were told they will be tested on the material
while the other half were told they would have to teach it to other students
participants expecting to teach it, did much better on understanding
when you're expected to teach, your brain organizes  the information in a more logical coherent structure
of course, practice, practice, practice!
not only do practice tests for your brains in your enviroment
but even if you make mistakes, they help identify gaps in your knowledge
practice test have also been proofed to increase confidence, then by leading to better performance
so where should you be studying ?
research shows that having a designated secret spot for studying , that is well equiped with every tool you might need is best
just like setting times , this primes your brain for studying
have an awesome study playlist? not so fast
well some studies have shown that certain types of classical music can help improve concentration
our recent studies have shown that learning with rhythmic background noise can be detrimental to focus
and those not using music , very much better
and if you haven't already, put away your phone!
it decreases concentration
of course, exams can be extremely stressful
so if you want some tips on how to deal with exam anxiety
check out our ASAP videos which brings down some tips for that
link is in the descripition
a big thank to the TD for sponsoring this video